the question for this week if you choose
to answer and you could take your time
is that's a rough one oh my god I don't
know that 60 year old people should
answer that question I'm not usually a
person who's lost for words either
that's the last thing how do you believe
in yourself I think I look back at
everything that I've overcome already
and just remind myself that I've gone to
those things that I've overcome them
so if I've already gone through all
those things and I can I do go through
the things that I'm going through now
I'm gonna answer it as like a win
because how is hard for me but I think
what I believe in myself this one I'm
most passionate about what I'm doing
like what I'm doing like my music and my
art and stuff like that that's what I'm
like damn Gina you're doing good getting
through the little battles every day
that's how I believe I believe in myself
by just constantly reassuring myself
like like vocally saying you know like
you know you can do it and constantly
it's constantly doing that causes you to
just believe
yeah like believing in anything you just
have to have faith that is there you
know
I have to be like I don't it doesn't
matter whether I make it or not
then if it doesn't matter there's not as
much stress on me so then I perform
better like that's just me though so
when you do them you care less about
weird it's like anti-climatic but okay
not caring less but like not stressing
about it as much because it's just
putting more pressure on you so
really how my parents ready to hit the
guy next to me could do it I can do and
if they're good worked any better than I
think there's a lot of conditioning from
when we're young to either make us feel
confident and believe in ourselves in
certain areas or not for instance here
you know really good at spelling or
you're good writer you're an artist I
think when someone believes in you and
you're young you just automatically
assume that they're right and and you
are good at those things I think if
you're ever given any negative feedback
when you're young about you know you're
not good at this or that then then you
go with it
you believe that about yourself so I
think a lot of it is actually exterior
unfortunately and
I know that the best thing for all of us
to do is work on ourselves and believe
in ourselves without having to worry
about what other people are thinking
about us
great question hard to do
I don't really like I know it sounds
weird but it's like just severe
depression a lot honestly I just don't
feel happy about most stuff that I do
I don't feel angry sad happy or anything
I'm doing what I love in life already
but just nothing really have you ever
had a point your life
when I was little probably you know what
may be changed or
I really just happened one day thank you
well you how could you say you do you
you you try to do the best you can with
what you have each day you know and as
the British say sometimes muddle through
and I've done okay so far you know I
believe myself enough to get to sixty
nine and a half years old you look fine
I don't that's okay I've an answer that
is is that the meaning of life or
anything there's nothing deeply
theologic about it but just kind of
works for me so I just landed in the
state's a few days ago to hike the PCT
it's called the Pacific Crest Trail it's
a very very long trail and I've been
living in Perris for the past three
years and I've been going through some
ups and downs over there and I think
that hiking the PCT now is kind of a way
to try and believe
so that's kind of how
that's it well you know you keep moving
and if you keep moving they can't throw
dirt on you are as what sir Elizabeth
Warren she was said to have what
persistent keep persisting how's that
the way I you know relate to others the
way I treat other people the way other
people treat me I guess it's just kind
of a leap of faith a lot of the time so
that would be my answer as long as I try
to be as clear as possible when
communicating with somebody about what I
want what I'm feeling at the moment I'm
just trying to be as honest with myself
and everybody else that's when I feel
like I can kind of start to believe in
myself first of all it's logical that
for me it starts like in my mind it's
logical and it feels
they don't make sense and then second of
all
I heard feeling to put into words but it
feels comfortable
throwing
essentially you feel like you know your
abilities even if you don't exactly know
what you're doing so I would I feel
comfortable that I trust my abilities I
get up every morning and I tell myself I
love myself when I look in the mirror
and then I'm beautiful and that helps me
to believe in myself I've learned what
my strengths are through all these years
like experiences I mean it's probably
not the right answer but I would say
that I believe in myself because from
the people around me believing in me
satella so if the people around you
didn't believe in you you think you
would have believed in you thought well
no I think that you can instill enough
love and somebody that it's a permanent
thing
I mean through self-discipline basically
by managed to do things that I'm glad to
do then if I get them done then I
strongly doing
that's how it works for me so can I ask
the ball question of course not can you
describe the feeling
it's like
it's very philosophical questions trying
to think of an example I'll be great
something like the story about the gold
diggers predictable and some of the gold
diggers give up because they can't find
the gold at some point there are people
who have to like discipline themselves
and motivate themselves to keep going
and and they get the gold so I think
it's just
it's very philosophical movement that's
- my name is Mariah and I'm the owner of
this channel I'm also the person behind
the camera and I thought I'd take a
minute to thank all the subscribers I
gained so far and maybe ask the new
years to hit the subscribe button if you
liked this episode or if you're a fan of
my channel in general a lot thank you